diplomatic relations between the United
States and Venezuela are continuing to
deteriorate tonight the u.s. no longer
recognizes Nicolas Maduro as president
of that country in response to that
Venezuela has ordered American diplomats
to leave Venezuela the US has not
complied the Trump administration now
says quote all options are on the table
regarding Venezuela could this lead to a
military conflict of some kind with that
country Fox News chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge has
been following the situation in
Venezuela very closely and she joins us
tonight with the report Thank You Tucker
and good evening Venezuela is much more
than a regional conflict with Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo confirming that
Iran has a significant footprint in
Venezuela and other Latin American
nations through the terrorist group
Hezbollah the FBI is seeking information
about an operative Ghazi nasir al-din
who is tied to Hezbollah and has Syrian
and Venezuelan passports based on recent
intelligence nasir al-din was operating
from venezuela sanctioned by the
Treasury Department he has at least 10
aliases and he's linked to clandestine
networks in Syria that amplified the
violence and fueled the Syrian refugee
crisis eventually drawing in the US
Russia and Iran national security
experts said a similar scenario may be
playing out in Venezuela latest
projections from the Brookings
Institution a Washington DC think-tank
our 8.2 million refugees and migrants
may leave Venezuela that is 25 percent
of the current population and now Russia
China and Cuba are backing the Maduro
regime we're fighting against external
and extra regional powers that are using
these countries as proxy conflicts
because they'd rather fight the United
States in a proxy battle then they would
fight the United States and any kind of
convention about in their home countries
his most recent interview President
Trump left the military option open but
significantly made no commitments Tucker
Catherine Herridge hystory we will
continue to follow thank you very much
for that Venezuela was once the richest
nation in South America Krakus basically
a first world city huge middle class
obviously massive oil reserves and then
that country got socialism now people
are starving in Venezuela millions as
you just heard have fled the crime rate
there is among the richest in the world
the income inequality also among the
most profound globally a small group of
leaders have become even richer everyone
else impoverished in other words it
didn't work and the president pointed
this out in a State of the Union on
Tuesday socialist policies have turned
that nation from being the wealthiest in
South America into a state of abject
poverty and despair
we are alarmed by the new calls to adopt
socialism in our country tonight we
renew our resolve that America will
never be a socialist country
[Applause]
some of the Congress scowled when the
president said that but it remains to be
asked are there lessons from Venezuela
that we should pay attention to mark
Penn thinks there are he was a pollster
for President Clinton he joins us
tonight mark thanks for coming on
tonight so what can the United States
learn from what has happened to
Venezuela well if you go back a little
bit in history Venezuela had a vibrant
democracy with two parties I actually
worked for two presidents bringing
poling to them and and the presidency
went back and forth the adecco is the co
piano's but neither party really
delivered for the people so they decided
to try socialism but once the Socialists
got in he dismembered all of the
safeguards like no reelection that were
preventing the return of basically the
kind of strong man dictatorship that
they had overthrown to have democracy
and then the economy went downhill and
then there were medicine food shortages
and now there's a huge humanitarian
crisis involving 30 million people right
here in our hemisphere and I think the
administration's policy is just and
right so you just utter the phrasing
wait the hair my arms go up you said the
problem was neither party delivered for
the people neither party made ordinary
people's lives better so they elected a
crazy person who broke everything I mean
should both parties be thinking about
how to deliver for people not
abstractions but results so we avoid
that on the day that the Green Deal that
might as well be called the red Deal the
way that it's really really structured
is released it is a warning that if the
parties don't get together compromise
and start delivering look Congress has
about a 13% approval rating this is what
happened in Venezuela
their enormous riches and normos
capability of moving that country
forward that could have been a model of
Latin America but instead both failed
they made a bad choice and once you make
that bad choice once you get someone in
here doesn't really believe in democracy
who believes in socialism instead they
get rid of the institutions like Free
Press
like the idea of reelection like a
Supreme Court with real judges and
that's what happened in Turkey that's
what we see happening here that's what
happens every time this the the that
people cross the line from democracy I
mean once you elect someone and give him
control over the army and the National
Police once all the guns are in the
hands of one person what what can you do
to stop a dictatorship well look right
now I think we have a really good chance
of returning Venezuela to the people of
Venezuela and and breaking this which
has gone on since 2002 now that I think
Colombia and Brazil and the other
countries and Europe is actually
supporting us so I hope we get Venezuela
and back to the Venezuelans it is a just
and fair cause and we take the lesson
the democracy is fragile no matter how
strong you think it is and I used to go
to rallies where a million people would
show up they would have universal voting
that it is fragile if we don't serve the
needs of the people and both parties
were to listen to that I couldn't agree
more vehemently mark Penn thank you very
much for that thank you